session of short talks and then the
remainder of the workshop today will be
some working group sessions
for the invited participants of the
workshop so I'll go ahead and pass
things to you and Eddie okay thank you
so
um
this this appears in the schedule as a
survey I should maybe start by a
disclaimer that this is far from a
comprehensive survey
um I in particular there's oh there's
been tons of work in the past few years
about improvements in in methods and
Analysis and I'm not gonna uh survey
that I think that'll be an interest in
Fairly limited uh audience here and more
my intent is to focus not on the the
answers but rather the questions and to
give more historical perspectives well
as you see I'll start with
um work from actually uh over 10 years
now
um on uh undistributed uh learning we'll
see how it aligns kind of with how we
think of it now and and then
um spend also some time
um talking about a particular analysis
uh framework again trying to highlight
um more its deficiencies rather than uh
um then it's strength and I should say
that
um this is uh um I asked some people
um to uh you know what do you think is
important that I uh cover
um uh Nina and Peter who's here servit
uh
um but what I say is entirely kind of my
biased view I'm not like you shouldn't
take this as representing uh these
people from which maybe I I got some
ideas but I didn't also actually follow
uh the suggestions uh and definitely
um I'm solely responsible for this uh I
will show quite a bit I see I think Nina
unfortunately wasn't I couldn't be here
and you'll see how there's like a
um some
um I do want to highlight some of her
work so we'll see that and also I should
say this is based on work of people
mostly want to highlight Blake uh that
really at least my work that I will
present is actually not my work it's
really Blake's work
um that I I was lucky enough to uh be
involved in okay
um let's start so
um so we're talking about
um I think
um
I'm not sure actually uh What ginger
said the distributed you say distributed
this is affiliate learning affiliate
optimization okay so I mean I I wanted
to start by getting off the way that
there's no from my mind there's
absolutely no distinction in learning
optimization just synonyms for the same
thing uh just make sure everybody is on
the same page here
um the the type of problems uh we're
going to be thinking of is stochastic
optimization problem
um I'll be talking only about these
stochastic optimization problems we want
to minimize some population objective
which is defined in terms of an
expectation with respect to uh some
unknown uh Source distribution D of some
uh instantaneous subjective f
um and we want to do that just based on
Sample access to uh to D okay so this is
uh a general formulation I mean
um maybe you want to think particularly
on supervised learning where your uh
your Source distribution your Randomness
Z is pairs of like uh example and label
um and maybe you're also used to
thinking of your optimization variable
not as X you know maybe X you think of
this the example and you're used to
think of your optimization variable is w
I know the weights of your network this
is a special case uh uh covered by the
more General formulation of course
included so in supervised learning and
if you are used to thinking of
optimization variable as W I'm sorry I
mean everybody is used to think of it
different ways uh and we're going to
take the optimization view here and
stick with X optimization variables so
from here on acceptance slides that I
forgot to change uh we're always
optimizing over X okay
um good but so this is a general uh so
far it didn't say anything I mean this
is a standard stochastic optimization or
or learning setup but we want to talk
about Federated or or uh distributed uh
learning or optimization in particular
um well when doing that there are a
bunch of resources to worry about so
there's all the resources we worry about
also when we talk about serial uh uh
stochastic optimization which you know
there's lots of work on uh in particular
the sample uh uh number of samples we
need in the the computer uh runtime
which are maybe the more uh most
significant uh but we would care we're
care we care about these distributed
settings in which in addition to um uh
to these resources the important other
important resources are the number of
machines or nodes or devices or or what
have you uh we're going to use and
significantly the communication like how
much we need to communicate and also
when you talk about uh compute now we
have to be a bit careful are you
counting kind of total computational
steps and of the energy or the latency
the the wall time and we'll see that
many of these differ but which of the
many of the approaches differ by which
resources they emphasize so in
particular
um they may be most a unique resources
here is the communication okay
um how many
um if we're going to orchestrate uh this
this uh optimization of across a bunch
of devices how many bits or of
information are exchanged and this was
the focus
um of
um early work by uh Nina Balkan from
Bloom shifina that
I think we're the first that formulated
a distributed optimization setting in in
a framework that can be analyzed by by
can be analyzed and would emphasize that
there were there was work before I think
Summerfield mentioned later on um
showing methods for distributed
optimization uh but what I want to
emphasize today is also analysis
Frameworks and for me for analysis
framework to be useful it has to be
specific and constrained enough that it
can also show lower bounds in it right
that I can actually argue kind of what's
optimal and what's best there has to be
defined rules okay so they Define what
um what they call the distributed pack
uh setup this is not the notation they
use but this is kind of mapping uh their
setup into the notation uh uh we're
going to use here I'm going to use here
um and so
um
they're um the way they they thought
about it um I should say many of these
bullet points were taken directly from
an uh Nina slides that you generously
shared with me
um uh if the data being distributed
across different locations so I can
think of it as in our language of
cross-silo uh uh corresponding cross
Silo situation
um where some of the distribution is in
every uh location is access to a part of
the distribution
um this uh um DM right the Distribution
on machine M and we want to learn with
respect to the mixture of distribution
across them okay so you can think of
taking the mixtures of course equivalent
to taking the mixture here the mixture
of the distributions or since uh
bilinearity of expectation just the the
average of the uh objective on each
machine okay and the real kind of
um difficulty here is reaching consensus
reaching a single solution uh um uh X
that's good on you know for all of these
machines or at least on average and the
main resources they thought they talked
about so in order to reach consensus
right if
um uh Katrina has some of the data and
John is some of the data and I have some
of the data in order to get something
that's good for all three of us we're
gonna need to talk right we cannot do
this without talking in the main
research so they looked at is how much
we need to talk right how much
communication and that's basically
pretty much almost the only resource
they really uh cared about here so if
you didn't particular as a communication
complexity problem you mapped it to a
formulasis communication complexity
problem they did they should say I'm not
going to talk about it here they did
talk also about issues or already in
2012 about issues of privacy and and
um okay they they talk they mentioned
they talked a bit about incentives uh
but did have actually results also uh
regarding privacy
um but you know this is Nina's sign here
the main thing was communication and and
they were aware of privacy and incentive
constraints
um okay so what what was their approach
um so they analyzed uh mostly the
realizable case so in the realizable
case uh in a binary classification
setting you just think of it as a
hypothesis that that is correct you know
all the data actually follows some
hypothesis uh more generally you can
think of it as just having
um take the loss to be not negative
almost everywhere and that means the
realizable case corresponds the fact
that there's a solution that actually
has zero error zero objective values so
in particular that means that there's
there's a single Solution that's good
for everybody right sort of thing so
Katrina is one of the data Johnson Epsom
of the data but there's a single X star
that's actually perfect both for Katrina
and for John and for me so this sounds
at first like okay what's the problem
just each one of us will work separately
if the optimum Katrina has the optimum
journalist Optimum I have the the same
optional just ear chalk noise but of
course that doesn't work because there
might be multiple uh the difficulty is
that each one of us might have multiple
different Zero Solutions but we need to
to talk to each other in order to find
the one that actually works for all of
us okay so this is even
um in this restrict setting the problem
is uh is non-trivial so one Baseline
here is that we just all collect enough
data and send this uh you know send the
data between us yep a small question
does the x-star need to be unique or can
there be no the extra does not need to
be unique so in general it would not be
any
so you can think of it you know
something to have in mind is think of
like uh
um you know a linear prediction right so
that's uh there's a headspace that's
good for all of us I'm sorry you don't
actually I didn't include that picture
maybe you should there's you know
there's a half space in good role of
thus of course each one of us has many
half spaces that are good right but
there's one that's good for all of us
but also for many filters okay
um so the the the kind of Baseline here
and it's important I think you know and
we'll emphasize there to think about
baselines because
in order for to for the analysis to be
meaningful we presumably one at the very
least we base better than kind of the
most trivial Baseline the most trivial
Baseline here is just collect enough
data to solve the problem statistically
and send it all around and each one of
us since we're only care about
communication once we did that we can
just all do it locally okay
um and that's requires communicating as
many samples than we need for for
learning which is correspond to the VC
Dimension divided by Epsilon if you want
to get an Epson accurate solution and
um Nina from uh
uh main contribution uh was a generic
method that uh is for any binary
hypothesis class so this is not not some
specific class but it's a very generic
method that allows reducing this
communication complexity roughly from
the VC Dimension times one over Epsilon
to uh VC Dimension Times log 1 over
Epsilon okay and this is done by with
log 1 over Epsilon rounds of
communication okay so we have here an
exponential Improvement in terms of
Epsilon okay
um and this is achieved with
um
uh um this is achieved with essentially
optimal or close to Optimal so sample
complexity and computation is not like
in this general setting when you talk
about General hypothesis class we can't
really talk about computation because
it's not like uh you know depends on the
hypothesis class and the way they did
this which I think is a it's an
interesting method that could be
relevant uh also now is essentially
using a boosting approach right so
um he was a boosting approach to figure
out which example so instead of Katrina
sending me all her examples and John
sending me off the examples we're going
to try to figure out which are the
examples I really need from Katrina in
uh and John okay so work uh like this uh
the method will work in rounds will need
a lot more okay log one over Epsilon
rounds and there's going to be one
distinguished prayer me okay so uh so
this is important there's one player
here that's going to do all the work
okay so I volunteer
um and in each round uh each player is
going to maintain some local
distribution rewriting distribution over
examples
um it's gonna it's gonna send me some
small number of examples based on these
uh small number of examples I'm going to
take these examples and what I've uh
before and produce a hypothesis any kind
of hypothesis
um and then as in boosting I mean this
is basically just an implementation of
boosting where I'm now gonna you know
send this hypothesis back uh to
everybody okay so I'm gonna and now now
John and Katrina got them sorry I keep
picking on you you're just your
uh the sitting in the front center
um uh uh each hypothesis each each
um of the nodes can now see you know
based on the hypothesis so this
hypothesis they know exactly all
hypothesis have so far and what you want
to do in boosting and is reweigh the
example so that hypothesis that don't
agree with the example are upgraded the
hypothesis they do agree with example
are downgraded and then in each uh
um uh each of the nodes each of the
players can do this independently can
reweigh the distribution almost
um we just need to normalize the overall
weight but that just requires sending
kind of the sum of the weights from each
player and exchanging that so one round
of broadcasting and
um
and based on that now each uh each of
the players can now send me back
examples the number of so there's two
kind of your weightings here one is
rewriting the the different nodes right
so I might want you know if
um this a path is also great for for
Katrina but like really horrible from
John I'm going to want more examples
from John and the second is you know
John and Katrina themselves are going to
send me more examples that are
disagreeing with are going to up
weighted examples that are disagreeing
with hypothesis I've so far and done
with the ones that I don't okay and this
way overall they're going to send me
instead of having to send me one of our
Epsilon examples or vco verbs and
examples the overall examples they're
going to need to send me they're going
to focus just on these more problematic
examples and reduce the number of
examples they're going to send me to uh
uh to just uh VC Times log one over
Epsilon so this is in some sense you can
think of it as a a method of reducing
communication by focusing and sending me
just the important examples and then the
second one note that the way I'm
counting also communication here is not
exactly in bits so there are two
resources I'm both counting bits of like
you know because we're going to send
these weights and that's going to be
counted in bits but also we're just
sending hypothesis right so the
um I count the number of examples of Z
is uh uh sorry
they need to send so I send examples
um I need to send
hypotheses in terms of implicitly right
so I've been telling them in terms of
the weights and the cities right um so
so the the the the unit we're sending is
is the the examples Yeah question yeah
what if there is no player that has
come in okay so it's a good question
um so at least in this talk and both in
this in their setting at least in their
main kind of Maintenance setting and
what I'm going to talk about there's no
connectivity issue so there's it's an
all to all connection and so we just
have one the way this view they view it
is everybody's connected to everybody we
pick one uh player and that player is
kind of the manager okay you can map it
to a you know in a cross-device setting
there's a very naturally kind of a
distinguished player right the server
um they um they do both uh Nina and
cothers talk a bit about uh over graph
and we'll see later on there's work by
uh RAM and co-authors uh that more
explicitly talk about what can you do in
um when your connectivity is limited to
a particular graph uh but I'm actually
intentionally not going to get into it
in this talk that's definitely an issue
um that I I think okay maybe I should
say in injecting also investors
separating between distributed
optimization and federal learning I
don't know like you know it's again the
same thing it's there's a different
regime to me one of the differences is
when talking about distributed problem I
feel like that the connectivity topology
is very important right so people talk
for example distribution you have sensor
Network and you want to like read some
consensus and sensor Network and then
you have you know the the topology is
super important in most applications I I
can at least think of and I'm sure that
many of you are now can raise their
hands and come up with a bunch of
exceptions
um instead of learning to me the
topology is the most important the the
communication is again either server to
devices or in a cross Silo setting where
it's you know the different locations
and I know but it's not you know
everybody Community can communicate with
everybody it's how they can really have
physical connectivity issues
um okay
um good okay so the main advantage of
this result is a very generic result
like you can handle any uh uh any
hypothesis class just in terms of
Dimension which is you know the right
parameter in some sense to capture
learning they also have some analysis
for specific hypothesis classes that
also take account into account uh more
specific computation constraint and uh
get in for these hypothesis classes this
this method is not optimal in general
but for the specific hypothesis the uh
um the study
um uh then they do show that this is
optimal now whether the hypothesis
classes are are uh um uh interesting or
natural or not I guess they can bring it
up with Adam uh no I'm not I'm just
copying uh um but at least I would say
that coming from kind of a call to
contention learning perspective uh these
you know formulas conjunctions parities
are at least well studied you know maybe
Adam will will agree with that uh could
we have Adam's approval you like
priorities yeah I don't like parities or
pain but okay uh they're good counter
examples okay
um good they also go beyond supervised
learning and I think they have I think
in my mind actually this is the maybe
the most interesting uh uh work here on
uh clustering and PCA problems so these
are problems where
now
um I have some of the data Katrina some
of the John songs and vectors we want to
find the cluster a joint clustering of
our data or even more interesting we
have a bunch of vectors we want to find
the Subspace uh that will be low
dimensional Subspace that will
approximate well all of our data and
this is a hard this is a um actually a a
hard problem again they study it in the
setting you know emphasize that here the
study is like in in a worst case sense
right so I have some arbitrary data
that's very different from Katrina and
very different from John's and yet we
still want to find Subspace that's good
for all of us
um okay so what are the limitations of
their approach well one thing at least
as presented it's specific to Binary
classification I don't think
um uh this is a very real restriction
the same idea is at least of boosting
can be generalized more generally uh
what is a real restriction here is
realizability okay so they really
realize very because we use boosting
boosting relies very heavily in
realizability and the fact that we do
have an office there exists an Optimum
that's an Optimum both for me for
Katrina and for John and we just need to
you know we don't like loot the fact
that I'm
um need to satisfy also John and Katrina
I don't need to compromise they should
still be Optimum this is a huge
restriction they do have I'm just going
to flash a slide here without going over
uh uh uh going over it in detail they do
have extensions to an agnostic setting
right where we we want to compete with
the best we can do an average to all of
us instead of optimum and these if those
are familiar these results uh
essentially without any kind of like
agnostic boosting results and you have
some uh
um
um they they stood on and it's just for
Stephen Nina and you can actually uh get
something better with the uh uh more
recent agnostic uh boosting but without
getting you want to ask about this line
I'm in trouble yeah dollars the
guaranteed error order options yeah yeah
okay right okay I I mean I would say
weak I don't know if dumb okay
um can you do better
optimal okay okay okay okay
so what John is complaining doesn't even
make sense what what John is rightfully
complaining about is that the type of so
the two problems with these extensions
to the non-realizable case
um okay let's actually talk about the
second one first
um this is completely non-tractable so
as opposed to the boosting approach
which you know okay yeah you have to
still depend on the hypothesis discuss
but for a reasonable hypothesis classes
it's very computationally retractable
and very reasonable to implement
um agnostic with agnostic boosting
approaches for those that are familiar
that are completely non-implementable in
you know none uh the run the theoretical
run time is humongous and they're also I
don't think anybody actually okay
probably somebody wrote code for it but
it's not like uh
um it's and again I've used this
techniques also in my papers and I
always feel like you know this is a bit
feels wrong because this is
unimplementable methods
um the second is as John pointed out
what we really want is if there's some
x-star that's good and you know I had on
average like I know 0.1 good for us I
want to be able to get error 0.1 plus
episode and instead what they insure is
there's some constant C okay which is
you know maybe 50 something like that
okay that's not very explicit and what
you can ensure is you get error 50 this
constant cannot be you know you cannot
drive it to to one it's like whatever
comes from their method times the
optimal error plus Epsilon okay so this
Epson fine we can get as close to that
but that means that if we have something
with error 0.1 maybe the best we can do
is there are five then you know what's
that good for right so this is this
means that the another way to view it is
we are going beyond the real the
realizable setting because now even if
the constant is 50 if the error is 10 to
negative 6 we're fine right we've got
you know five times as negative five
okay that's not so bad okay so in some
sense what this means is it's not that
you can handle a situation with any
error but we can at least handle a
situation with some there's some small
enough error that we can handle okay
maybe that's a way that John still
making faces but okay that's what you
get here and they think that uh this is
maybe it's a very significant limitation
here the the other limitation of um
um uh um of uh this oop where is it
um of this approach is that they really
the only resources uh concerning is
communication
um the computation actually you know we
don't save it all in compute versus a
completely serious implementation in
fact this is at the end I'm doing all
the work and I'm gonna just do a
completely straight up serial
implementation so I'm not using the fact
that actually uh uh John and Katrina can
also actually compute okay
um so that's uh another issue here but
at least again it's it's a well-defined
question and a solution that is uh
significantly improves over based based
on at least in a realizable case
um as far as I know
um the non-realizable like what can you
do in a non-realizable case is still uh
open here in this uh generic setting I
should say that this type of approach is
also very similar
um you know briefly mentioned before to
a line of work by um
um uh a Ned you can uh students
um the and many others as well
um which didn't think about a learning
setting but just as a Distributive
consensus problem okay and here indeed
I'm kind of doing a uh this Justice
because most of the work here is
actually about how does the connectivity
graph communication graph affect things
okay but if we forget the communicative
graph which is the main point in this
line of work
um then what we get back is
essentially is something which is
equivalent in some sense to uh to the
Belkin at all setting then again we have
each machine has a different local
objective so in in Belkin setting when
you can think of this local objective as
a expectation over a different
distribution I mean they just think of
it as an objective that you can have
arbitrary access to but again if we
don't care about if we're not if we're
only counting Community communication
and that number of samples then it
doesn't really matter and it's the same
thing and we want to minimize this the
the average of office so which uh
consensus and then here most of the work
is not in the realizable setting uh and
um the in the work here is mostly like
the number of vectors exchanging again
this is I think a weakness of this line
of work is that there's not a
well-defined framework here in the sense
that what is a vector exchange you know
you can compress everything I want into
a single Vector but I know multiplexing
uh digits or something like that and so
there aren't as far as I'm aware in this
line of work actually uh so it's not a
framework in which you can you can get
lower bounds because you can kind of
cheat and you can instead of that talk
about bits maybe but this is not
generally done in this line of work as
far as I'm aware so it's they're methods
but not really
um uh
maybe not it's not a framework that you
can actually the rules are not well
defined here for this game okay but
mostly
um
what I want to emphasize and hear also
the emphasis is mostly just in
communication and not in computational
though all of the methods studied here
are very easy computationally to uh to
implement but
the other
um main thing maybe that I want to
emphasize it's I think very different
from this work from uh about uh 10 to 12
years ago by uh
um Ramen oil and and uh Balkan at all
um
is what are we trying to do here so
where's the difficulty coming from and
what do you want to do so in both of
these the main difficulty stems from the
fact that we have very different
distributions very different objectives
we want to try to reach consensus in the
these you know the the hard cases the
cases where I have to communicate a lot
are those cases where our objectives are
going to be very different or
distributions are going to be very very
different okay
um and I want to contrast that with a
case that I find uh uh very uh
interesting and I think is very relevant
in federal learning and actually that is
where I would at least start as a
Baseline and that's an homogenous case
where it's not that each one of us has a
different distribution actually all of
us have access to the same distribution
uh Katrina as a button you can get
examples from the distribution John can
get examples from same distribution I
can get examples from the same
distribution and in this case we
actually don't need to communicate at
all okay we we don't need to be friends
each one of us can work on our own press
the button as many times as we need and
learn independently and the way that we
oh how how am I doing in time actually
okay
um the way that I uh and and really the
the
um the goal here is to leverage the fact
that we can communicate in order to do
things better so the fact that there are
many nodes many players should only help
us as opposed to all this work and uh
both uh Nina's framework and and uh the
distribute consensus the more players if
now instead of just having the three of
us suddenly there's room of 20 of us the
problem becomes harder it's like oh my
God you know there's this there's a
linear scaling there on the number of
notes whereas really if we're just
trying to work together to solve a
problem having more of us should just
help us or to completely reverse
dependence on a number of machines
um and I think this is the kind of main
thing here they want to try to do
something collaboratively and reach uh
uh consent or sin there has been work on
trying to apply in some early work and
serve optimization apply this
distributive consensus problems as a
primitive and or on the empirical
objective but again any any method
that's based on that will necessarily
have this like in Reverse dependence on
what we want in a number of machines
which is say things become harder we
have our machines which is wrong okay
and something we maybe probably not get
to later is even in the setting where
the uh where maybe we do have different
distributions I'd still argue the
dependence should always be that if
there's more of us then things should be
easier and not harder and there there
are several ways to think about it
um well one is maybe we're different but
hopefully we're not all that different
otherwise what's the point we'll just
like work separate you know we don't
gain anything we don't there's nothing
saying that we need consensus in fact if
each of us has different distributions
right so if my text is actually in
Hebrew in John's text is in English and
Kat Venus checks this in French and
having like that and there's like no
connection between uh those languages
then there's no reason to reach a single
predictor that's good for everything I
mean each one of us can just have their
own private predictor right so you can
think of the objective as not finding a
single X hat that works for everybody
but this machine specific exact and
again the hope is that by working
collaboratively we can leverage the
similarities and work less but rather
than you know fight hard on the cases
where we disagree okay
um and in any case the The Guiding
principles again having more nodes more
machines will only help us and not not
hurt us
um
um and the other is that we want to
emphasize also computation not just uh
communication so the framework that uh
um okay let me pick up pace a bit so now
uh because otherwise I'm never going to
finish
um so in particular to study computation
uh what I'm going to describe so so far
I described this uh distributed pack
learning do mostly to uh Nina Balkan and
co-authors I'm gonna switch to talking
about a different analysis frame and I
want to again emphasize analysis
Frameworks in this analysis framework
does address these concerns and also
talks more directly about computation in
order to do that okay getting lower
bounds in computation is impossible
nobody can actually get lower bounds in
computation I mean except for you know
it's ridiculously uh the artificial uh
problems right um or using complexity
assumptions but I don't know any
complexity that's too hard for me okay
so instead what we're going to do is a
surrogate my items maybe Adam can do
that but not me uh so what we're going
to use as a surrogate is what is a
standard approach in in convex
optimization we're gonna instead of
counting computation counting gradient
accesses we're going to allow accessing
our function only with uh through a
particular Oracle exorcism and for now
at least let's just look at first order
Oracle and we're going to use the number
of gradients we calculate as a surrogate
for computation at least we can now get
lower bounds and say any method that's
going to use gradients is going to have
to do at least this many steps to this
amount of work okay and
um okay for now this is we'll get back
to I mean the technical assumptions
we're going to look at the next few
slides we're going to look at the convex
smooth convex objectives with the you
know for a bounded domain and euclidean
space that's not so important because
I'm not going to cover details so much
in this has been this type of framework
has been extremely successful in uh in
serial optimization we basically just
know the answer okay and we know the
answer in a very like pretty much any
setup you can come up with we know the
answer okay so in particular we know
with the first order stochastic Oracle
we know what the best you can do is and
more importantly we know which method
achieves it okay and in the namely
that's just accelerated stochastic grade
indecent okay and this is a real thing
like this it's not just the
theoretically this is kind of min max
optimal but it really is a good method
and whatever says this method was also
um
um a result of studying the analysis
framework so historically when people
looked at gradient descent okay and then
they tried to show let's try to prove
gradient descent is optimal okay for a
non-smooth objective is it is optimal
try to prove it's optimal for non-smooth
objectives right so it is important
there's analysis framework you can prove
lower bounds guess what it's not optimal
for nuns for smooth objectives okay so
this was you know after years of trying
to show that it is optimal the
industrial showed that actually it's not
optimal there's a better method here
namely acceleration that's true of
acceleration which is related to
momentum okay and and this is really a
nester of acceleration it's a direct
result of thinking in terms of both
upper bounds and lower bounds and of the
fact that you have an analysis framework
in which the problem is well defined the
rules of the game are well defined and
you can think about lower bounds okay so
this is a Serial case we kind of know
all the answers and you know this is
good for serial computers the question
is what happens you know in a
distributed setting okay so the the main
analysis framework that we've at least
been studying in the past few years is
this uh the stereo optimization with
intermittent communication okay so here
um you can think of it as a anything a
bunch of servers and a cross Silo
setting and each machine can do can
sequence do sequentially uh gradient
accesses you can query any point any you
know creating access at any point okay
um but cannot communicate the K gradient
accesses and then there's a round of
aggregation where everybody can
communicate with everybody right and
we're not counting here now how many
bits you can communicate but just how
frequently you can communicate although
again all the methods really the
communication boils down to exchanging a
vector or a few vectors okay and then uh
and this repeats in many rounds so we
have the parameters here are rounds K
number of gradients per machine per
round and M machines so this is in a
kind of cross silo or server uh setting
but you really have the the same type of
uh computation structure going on also
in a cross-device setting okay so in uh
cross-device Federated learning at least
um the way I think if I describe it here
and this matches the description by um
uh uh constantly at all and and many
others uh we have a bunch of uh notes a
bunch of devices in each round
we get a bunch of them okay and then
each of those devices can execute some
gradient uh uh oracles on its
distribution but again we're thinking of
this still is homogenous that all the
you know the the data is imaginous
across uh across machines and then send
it back to the server the server again
samples a bunch of machines and so forth
so even though this looks very different
right I have different different
um machines operating at each round and
the communications all through the
server if you look in terms of the
computational structure it's the same
computational structure in both cases
okay and we formalize this this is work
also with the Adam and um again mostly
by uh uh Blake Woodworth uh formulas
this is a uh uh in terms of a graph
Oracle model where you have you know
oracle access the functions a range in a
communication structure defined by a
graph and this is a one particular case
of learning and this allows us studying
both upper bounds and importantly lower
bounds understanding good exactly what
the optimal methods here
um I should say um maybe I'll go over
very quickly without actually I'm going
to flash some equations but I'm going to
time to go over them the the the the
framework is the same in both the cross
device and and
um
uh in Cross Silo in the sense that you
know it's the answer you know the
parameters here are the same parameters
a number of machines M number of uh
rounds are and number of gradients per
per round what's different and so you
know once you know the answer you know
the min max sample complexity for this
then you just know the answer how do you
use it in the in the how you use it and
how you interpret it in different
settings varies because
in particular what's uh flexible and
what's fixed is different in these
settings in the cross Silo setting the
number of machine number of machines
which is a number of servers number of
silos number of hospital is fixed right
we're doing a collaboration among 17
hospitals we just have 17 hospitals we
can now say oh actually I need 19. you
don't have 19 you just have 17 okay uh
what you can what you can change is how
frequently you can communicate okay we
can you know I would like to communicate
as little as possible this is a few
rounds but that's something flexible and
so really the question to ask once we
understand the min max complex you can
ask what's the minimum I think it's uh
okay I'm not again I'm not going to go
over the I'm not going to explain you
any of these equations because of the
time but I can ask you know what is the
minimum I can communicate by still you
know being uh optimal you know in the
cross uh across device setting the game
is different okay the number of devices
now is flexible okay I can use a
thousand uh devices per round they can
use ten thousand I can use thirty
thousand devices per round that's
flexible the number of rounds I do is
kind of fixed because I'm going to train
for five six days I know and that's you
know as many rounds as they can do in
those uh five days okay but again you
can now ask using the same math you can
ask a different question which is if I
want to be you know do the best I can
over in the after five days how many
devices do I need each time okay how
many devices again do I need to collect
okay so just um there's okay so what's
the answer here
um so first of all we have to think of
the Baseline methods one Baseline method
is
don't take advantage of the local uh no
local updates you just take compute use
all these gradients to computer uh get a
tight grading estimate at a single point
okay so you just compute use all of
these pink grains to calculate your
grain in a single point
um and so using effectively a k times M
size mini batch and then just do
stochastic grading descent with this
mini batch okay
um and we understand the uh the analysis
and I'm not gonna
um uh I'm not gonna go over the
equations here you can think of them for
now just as pictures I'm going to talk
about them instead of going over them
because
um Ginger is going to kick me out in
five minutes
um uh but you can get some analysis and
this is you know what I consider
Baseline method you can do a bit better
than that because we said before that
SGD is actually not optimal you can
accelerate it so you can talk about
accelerated uh meaning back to SGD okay
and this is one Baseline you can ask is
this the best you can do well it's not
always the best you can do it there's
actually an even simpler Baseline that
sometimes is better than that an even
simpler Baseline says forget all the
machines okay I don't need Katrina and
John I'm just going to work on my own
okay and just run stochastic grading
Center again accelerates the custom
gradient descent just on my uh examples
okay so that in some regimes that
actually better right so if I
communicate very infrequently I'm doing
many many more updates and this is
actually better okay the question is can
you beat these two baselines okay you
know for a method to being justifiable
it needs to be used and the the main
method you'd you know that seems natural
here which is we already heard about
yesterday's uh what I call local STD or
Federated averaging Federated SGD I mean
it goes by by a bunch of names the
basically the idea is that I'm just
going to try to take the Best of Both
Worlds I will calculate you know use all
the machines and instead of just
calculating all the grains at the same
point I will actually do local updates
and the end I'll average everything and
I can take another step and there's been
many attempts at uh um analyzing local
STD and when we started looking at it it
seemed that all of them are actually
worse than the baselines okay so you can
get a guaranteer but the guarantee
actually doesn't show any Improvement
about this much simpler method which is
meaning by GST so what's going on here
um so
um it turns out that you can actually
improve in some regime so we have a
slightly tighter analysis that shows
that in some regime actually you can
improve over meaning back to STD okay
um but surprisingly what we found is
sometimes we can improve over many
batches 2D but not always in this first
bothered us it seemed like the analysis
was wrong and then we saw that no this
is true you really can you can show it
we can show a lower bound on local SGD
and this lower bound is worse than the
mini batches to the upper Bound in
certain regimes okay so it seems that
the picture here is a bit more
complicated this method that you'd see
You'd think would always improve
actually sometimes maybe is better but
sometimes it's not and you can see this
empirically so Mini battery is the green
uh sorry uh local streets the blue line
here frequently it's better but in some
parameter regimes in particular when we
have a lot of machines and very few
updates per machine it's actually worse
than minibatch sdd it's actually even
worse than something distributor which
is using a single
gradient per machine per iteration which
is okay
um so uh
um
um so this is again our analysis local
Studio can actually improve this again
by adding acceleration so this is a nice
work but you you on and Mom and the
question is okay so can you actually get
can you improve in further can you show
benefit in um something to note is that
even though local 3D does improve over
many batch sdd it actually only improves
over mini batch sdd in settings in which
this single machine approach is is
dominant so in so these guarantees for
Excel for even accelerate local SGD do
not improve over they improve over one
Baseline but do not improve over the
combination of these two very simple
baselines okay and again we're back in
this situation we cannot actually
justify local Studio the only case in
which local is to the control
Improvement number for Mini battery is
when there's an even simpler method that
is better
um okay so what's going on here can we
really you know this low cost really
really not work well
um
uh let me uh skip this and just say that
in one setting in which it does work is
if your objectives are quadratic then
turns that then you can show that local
HDD really is better dominates both mini
batch OCD and uh
um and and single machine and it's
optimal but then something even stranger
happens that all you need to do is local
sdd with a single step of communication
you don't just need to do average at the
end or one shot okay and this would be
optimal yes John why are we saying Sigma
on square root m is optimal if we have
quadratic objectives it shouldn't it be
Sigma squared on them
it's not strongly context
wait what's your problem because we have
quadratic shouldn't we always be getting
that worst sort of a one-on
one on uh K rate or
one on the number of iterations type of
Great One On sample size because it's
quadratic no only if you're uh
um
[Music]
no you not if you're uh no you don't get
if you're noisy in a noisy quadratic not
strongly convinced then you don't
understand how can you how can you be a
noisy quadratic which is not strongly
convex then there should be an
interpolating solution right yeah so no
why
yeah but it's not it's noisy right so
it's not the domestic objective variance
yeah the variance doesn't go to zero and
so okay the pointing is a variance
doesn't go we're not in a realizable
case the variance doesn't go to zero
when the the optimum but then we're
strongly convex right
what what if your population reactor is
quadratic or what direction do you have
that's not strong
like two two yeah really bad Optimal
Solutions you can have the generate
directions you can have an entire
Subspace you have an entire Subspace of
uh of solutions you can have very very
slow spectral Decay so remember these
are Dimension independent bounds
significant arbitrary slow spectral
decay
and then uh in the Hilbert space you can
have already
okay okay
so sorry so we're just making the thing
very poorly conditioned yes
okay uh okay the point here is that for
quadratics we only need to do average at
the industry so that's actually kind of
good news we don't have to communicate
at all but that's just for the quadratic
case Okay uh what happens in another
case so they're actually something that
I found even more surprising it turns
out you can show a lower bound here
that's not a coincidence we could not
improve over these two baselines because
these two baselines are actually optimal
no method can improve over those two
baselines okay okay so what does this
tell us
um and I'm gonna wrap start wrapping up
um so in this particular setting we
could kind of like analyze we can get
you know you apply our analysis
framework and just get the answer right
this is kind of what I want we have a
min max we know exactly what the
complexity is and we have an optimal
method okay and the optimal method is
just doing mini batches 3D or single
machine you know one of Mini battery and
the single machine SUV
um the question is dissatisfying so the
answer to me is this is extremely not
satisfying because this is does not
agree empirically with their
observations that local HD frequently
improves over meaning but over uh
minibus 3D and also by the way in the
quadratic setting also the answer is not
sort of thing quadratic setting we see
that local history improves but average
at the end just communicating once is
optimal but what we see empirically is
they're communicating many times even
the quadratic setting helps us and to me
what this means is is that we just this
is not the we have to refine our
analysis framework we have to think a
bit better about what are the conditions
under which we get we you know local
issue D we we actually get Improvement
um let me skip this
um I also briefly want to mention here
another setting we don't understand
completely is heterogeneous setting I
don't have time to go over we we do have
some upper balance and some lower bounds
and the key thing is how do you measure
through genuity and we do not for any
way of measuring into genuity we do not
know you know for any reasonable way we
don't actually know uh the answer we
have
some upper bound some lower bounds are
actually tight even with either with
zero heterogeneity meaning homogeneous
well not necessarily either zero to
dignity for some measure of adrenuity or
arbitrary value but for intermediate
Ingenuity we don't know actually the
answer and an even more interesting
setting uh
we talked about this a bit even more
interesting setting which I think is
completely understudied and again we
don't have the answer is this uh the
real setting we're interested in in
which we have a population over machines
with each with a different distribution
each time we're sampling a random set of
these so this is kind of a partial
participation setting again we do not
know the uh the min max rates here okay
let me uh summarize uh what I showed you
is in in the second part is an analysis
of one particular analysis uh framework
in one particular setting and I think in
in going forward even in Nets so a net
setting kind of got a min max uh uh
answer but we don't you know don't know
if it's useful but let's see what what
else we can go so first of all there are
many analysis settings that are
completely well defined and I kind of
skip the slides here very quickly but I
could Define them perfectly formally and
again I completely set the rules there
is an answer there is an index rate
there is an optimal algorithm I would
like to know what it is and I think
that's completely attainable and that
includes your genie is setting partial
participation setting none could back
settings or what I talked about is only
for convex we do have you know we as a
community right have uh upper and lower
bounds for non-convex optimization again
non-convex serial optimization we're
actually getting a pretty good
understanding of now we do have actually
in some sense uh we know the min max
answer but none convex distributed uh is
completely open during these huge gaps
um and um even more so for using a
higher order if we we talk about how
using higher order uh
um this is all with gradients we can
also ask the same question we have
various high order or other types of
accesses it can can improve here and are
open in incorporating other uh uh
constraints that come most more from uh
uh system modeling in another uh
question I think is interesting so far
we talked only about counting rounds of
communication but not actually bits
exchange and you can think of reducing
rounds of communication as a way of
reducing communication like but you can
also reduce communication just by
exchanging less bits and there's a lot
of work a lot of it by uh Peter uh also
on using actually compression techniques
for compressing uh um uh the gradients
either with some unbiased estimator for
gradients or keeping actually the top K
coordinates
um uh including uh work uh with the
error feedback framework it's supposed
to work for doing this compression more
more effectively especially for for
analyzing this is open but I think even
more interesting than analyzing these
specific methods is trying to think of
what is the right analysis framework
we're clearly missing something here
um
the fact that we do not have any uh
assumptions under which local HTT is
actually better than mini batches to the
average at the end or a single machine
which are all very kind of stupid bass
lines says that we're really missing
something here we really don't
understand what makes federal learning
or distributed learning actually works
um and and we don't know how to measure
heterogeneity I mean I think it's cute
we do want to talk about opportunity and
we don't know whether it's the right
quantitative measure to say how to how
similar to distributions okay we have a
bunch of different ways of doing it and
just by the fact that we have a bunch of
different ways you can already know that
we don't know what the right way is okay
um and also what is the right especially
into junior setting what is the right
objective we should care about should we
really care about the average over the
machines I mean why average of the
specific machines we have I don't think
that's particularly interested maybe the
worst case the worst case over some out
of sample of other machines and there's
a bunch of different objectives to talk
about energy in a setting and it's not
clear what which is there one we should
care about
um so this is I think the the the the
places where it's particularly
interesting to think about both the
application perspective the system
perspective and uh the optimization
perspective last note before already
over time way over time I'm sorry
um but but I think this is important
another thing that I think is I didn't
have time to talk about it I think is
super important
um is that regenerity not only of the
data but the interaction of the data
Ingenuity with the
um I would say machinistringenuity
that's both hardware and communication
and availability reliability Ingenuity
um in in the fact that these two are not
independent creates a lot of problems so
if the machine integenuity and the data
Trinity were independent right so you
each machine had an you know an
independent you know communication delay
an independent sourcing that would be
fine but the fact that machines which
have particular Hardware characteristics
tend to have also correlated data so for
example you know machines which are
maybe older phones have to have uh you
know that maybe certain languages are
more prevalent in older phones rather
than your phones phones that have less
reliable connections can really create
situations uh where you're starving out
a significant portion of population so
think about even a setting where you're
each time you're using a bunch of
machines but they have varying delays
and you don't have time to wait until
the one with the longest delay so you
just take you know the the first half of
the machines that respond right if all
your machines with a particular data
characteristics are always late you're
just never going to see that data and
how to handle this while not complete so
the solution of saying I'm just going to
wait for everybody that's going to slow
down everybody and again and be unfair
for machines that do have a lot of data
how to actually handle these situations
is I think particularly uh challenging
so okay I think I can take the question
after uh Ginger Cuts me off but uh
thanks I'm gonna get that up again
for yeah first of all
any questions for Daddy maybe one quick
question just a quick comments for this
different processing all right now we
have a Minimax
okay
so you know you talked a little bit
about the pack setting and then about on
the convex
sorry yeah so do you like a lot of these
questions make sense in
in either of the settings I mean
you have a sense of like you know as a
community we've certainly drifted more
towards
I'm trying to understand continuous
continuous settings because
uh you know most relevant say the Deep
Nets but like do you think trying to
understand these questions in the pack
setting
uh you know still still has something to
teach us yes so I I think that we
shifted towards a continuous uh for two
reasons uh one is because well that's
what we're we're doing I mean you know
we moved away from learning decision
trees to learn neurons
um and
um and definitely nobody's learning
conjunctions right in public acceptance
and the second thing is that there's
something appealing about that we can
actually talk about we have a good
circuit for runtime
VC setting with abstract hypothesis
classes it's very difficult to actually
talk about runtime
um so because of those two reasons I do
think the right thing to look at is
listening however I do think we can
learn a lot so the boosting ideas uh for
example that
um
uh suggested I think are very relevant
like boosting is definitely applicable
also in the continuous setting okay
um and so I do think we have a lot to
learn from that and think about in terms
of thinking about things but
but I I do want to stay oh
um
there's a whole bunch of techniques
which are not coverage
the The Continuous framework does allow
us to reason about adding realization
so again I skipped that very quickly but
it does definitely allow us to to talk
about that the answer by the way is that
you don't gain by adding explicit as SGD
already has in some sense regularization
right but you don't gain in terms of
index rate by adding explicit
organization on top of that uh but it
definitely does allow us to to consider
that
yeah
you mentioned it yeah so there were
suggestions I think actually but uh
Ginger and coffee maybe also for you
guys of adding like elastic terms which
are a form of explicit organization in
each outer step
um but but these things are provably
don't help in Within These set of
assumptions right so under other
assumptions maybe they do help and
definitely
and I think we're let's think Daddy
Again
[Applause]
all right so now we have a session of
short